pendant que se développent les discours
pavé de bonnes intentions sur la paix
chacun s'arrange pour bien préparer la
guerre aux cases où les états unis ont
ainsi procédé hier soir au lancement de
la navette spatiale militaire atlantis
tandis que le secrétaire d'état
américain à la défense a annoncé pour sa
part que pour la première fois son pays
avait réussi à suivre un missile dans
l'espace à partir du sol et grâce à un
rayon laser
autrement dit c'est un pas de plus dans
le programme américain de la guerre des
étoiles
patrick esther on peut parler d'
interdire la militarisation de l'espace
on peut demander l'arrêt des projets de
défense et spatial mais n'est ce pas
déjà un peu tard
hier cette navette atlantis entièrement
réservé aux militaires américains
décoller avec dans sa soute deux
satellites ultra secret en janvier
dernier un énorme satellites espions
avaient déjà voyagé à bord de discovery
à vandenberg en californie
un nouveau pas de tir de navette a été
spécialement construit exclusivement
pour l'élite
le 13 septembre le pentagone procéder à
la destruction d'un de ses vieux
satellite grâce à un missile assad
accrochés au décollage sous ce chasseur
f-15 le même jour en expériences
réalisées avant qu'un laser de faible
puissance permettait d'illuminer une
fusée sont évoluant à plus de 700 km
d'altitude
il y a deux semaines un autre laser
chimiques très puissant celui là était
utilisé pour détruire au sol un premier
étage de missile intercontinental
simulant une fusée soviétique nucléaire
la guerre des étoiles et déjà déclarés
aux norad
le réseau américain de surveillance
spatiale 5000 objets sont suivis en
permanence
une centaine d'entre eux sont des
satellites militaires encore en service
la majorité de ses yeux et de ses
oreilles électronique et soviétiques
il ne faut pas oublier du reste que le
premier satellite détruits dans le vide
cosmique était soviétique et qu'il avait
été cassé il y a cinq ans par un autre
satellite médine urss